so he could he
could no nina how stop
fighting he
said yeah that is what I
want what you try
to
that's stop you're going to make it work
stop they're not going to do business
okay you just said that I'm going in
right I'm going in you go
you is this for of them what what
about but he said we going to run the
tap you got got you know what he said he
said we going to run the tapes okay we
see wait she try to hit me or kick me or
some
this
guys babe babe babe y got to leave guys
you guys are rebooked for tomorrow I
know my rights okay to me hey guys
they're not going to let you fly tonight
yeah but it doesn't matter they're not
going to let you fly tonight why are
they not going to let me fly nothing WR
I'm going call the cops the tape hey hey
what's your name what's your name what's
your first name Jason it doesn't matter
what the tape show they're not going to
let you fly tonight so why he had listen
to me why he had to say that and
threaten me like oh I'm run this to
listen to us we're we're here now you
guys are listen you guys it's not about
Sid you guys are rebooked for tomorrow
but but
that's you're not going to make you I
know my right you're not going to make
it I know my right this doesn't have
anything to do with right the thing yes
I do yes I do I could call no hang up
you call complain
and I'll fight shut up guys come on I'm
going to come with you we're going to
go you guys are do you have your stuff
for being Reed for tomorrow your for
tomorrow you can't get this
FL they can't they canel it do you see
how they contradict why let you fly do
you hear how they trying to contradict
they they thought that I was in they
said that both of us was in I get it
listen and then they're like oh no you
get on but she can't then they're like
because she tried to kick you like oh r
on the video we need to go okay we're
can I see the cameras though come that's
what he said all right but I have
freedom or right that's what he said
though you have to leave the airp all
right I'm going to leave the airport but
can I
have my right can I have and be like I'm
not taking anybody's word you're not
allowed to be here because you don't
have a flight tonight I have a flight
tonight no you don't you're can 1734
listen you're rebooked for tomorrow can
I have the camera for me we're trying to
guys trying to what cuz now you can
arrest me right now then because you
know what I know my fucking rights
nobody's
intoxicated I did
not he just said it he's like yo I could
I could go then he's like yo she try to
kick me footage where hey you need to
leave the air side or you're going to be
arrested for trespass so show me the
footage how she going be arrested to
trespass
she got the booking so arrest me hold on
hold on how she going to get arrested if
she has the the boing the boarding pass
let's go now the boing pass let's go you
put in your boing passes for tomorrow
footage so let me get the boarding pass
you're listen listen you are trespassed
how am I trust I got a ticket me listen
to me you put it in your pocket it's for
it's for tomorrow not now for today no
no it's for tomorrow let's go let's go
tomor leave don't touch me you need to
leave don't touch me okay that's where's
the female officer female officer don't
touch me let's go leave can I get the
pass yes leave you need to leave you
need to leave too you need to leave Chad
look at me right now leave can I get the
boarding pass turn around and walk we
are going to walk with you and you will
get your boarding passes I'll take it
out and we'll
leave let's go thank you okay let's
go they all a bunch of Lies though no
I'm not taking anyone side CH please say
oh watch the video watch the tape oh he
try to I'm I'm going to smack the shit
out of you in seconds well don't do that
please is this all your
stuff hey is this your stuff guys it's
my
stuff you need to go I'm used to the
shitu I'm walk you out I'm
not
one one on the other
side when we get when we get across to
the main
terminal
when we get to the other side buddy
let's go come on stop stop playing games
really got to
go so
P I want out take a picture I'll take a
picture let's go do you remember know
how to play the game Let's Play cuz
guess what I don't like fucking
rights you got a PE
I do that make yeah you ain't got to pay
a fucking dollar so here's the thing if
you this way guys this way you
want if we're going to sit here and
cause the
disturbance let's go there wasn't
disturbance there was she's screaming
causing a disturbance now because you
right and because I came but before that
there was distur so listen so when so
when there's a disturbance
highly intoxicated but that I could the
flight but she couldn't it do matter but
we got past that so they called us and
you don't have I called you and you
don't have a flight so listen bro I had
a flight yeah but they canceled it right
here this way this way this way this
way so you're rebooked for tomorrow you
don't have any business over here
tonight so you can't be over here
causing disturbances or be over here
nothing I'm just trying to get on my
flight okay we want you to get on your
flight that's why we're trying to keep
everything calm bro
we're trying to get you home right over
here iy to get me home I just asked you
to tell them we don't tell them run the
footage cuz that's what they told me
they like when the cops come they're
going to run the footage you're going to
see that that something happened like
that she tried to kick me when they were
Al
completely if they decide they're not
going to book you and rebook you we
don't have any control no they already
no it's not bad this is INS same can you
tell her come on we're trying to be real
chill can you tell her come on
caution do not enter the are cling
please wait for the next train caution
do not enter the doors are cling please
wait
for do are please wait for the Alex I
can't get to that phone right now where
esting people over
the you know what I
know
shut come back tomorrow tomor so what
paperwork do I have that my my flight
tomor what paperwork do I have that
you're going to go to jail no so take me
to jail I don't want
to I don't want to stop because you know
what my mouth is greater and I know my
rights and I know what the fuck is right
I didn't do gun type shit at the end of
the day I really didn't but right now
you you're going to be done fucked
up I'm going to stop we didn't
start nothing they said going to run
you're intoxicated I'm not intox they
said about me and I was stop yelling
prove it stop pick up your purse no fuck
the purse
okay prove that we're just trying to get
you on your flight tomorrow yeah I want
my flight today but you don't have one
now I do and I can prove it that I do
they canceled it ma'am yeah why they
canel it for what reason this reason for
I was not like this I there she was on
the phone there was nothing wrong
nothing come on let's get on this please
don't leave your
Pur come on let's get on the thing there
something wrong with me okay get your
purse no you can't even look at me
though but again get your purse I've
been looking at you the entire time get
your all right I'll get my purse right
now but you need to hear me I hear you
there's cameras that's spage if you want
to make a complaint about Delta you can
call their for make okay that's fine
I got a daughter who's winning for me
tomorrow I just got a phone with ACS in
Brooklyn I can call them right now it
doesn't it doesn't change that they
canel your flight right but why there's
a reason why they can they said you were
intoxicated okay what they said and what
PO is oh it appears that you are
intoxicated no I'm not so is the camera
footage there's no camera footage man
there has to be about you being
intoxicated I can tell your entire you
want a pet yes I do want that's how good
I can call right now okay pick your
stuff up call right now you need to
leave so where's the camera
Fin's the
camera this is not do this is the last
time we're going to tr doing your job
you're doing your job I get it please
pick yourself up so we can get so we can
get you out of here so you can f no I'm
not getting out of here cuz at the end
of the day you're doing your job and
rightfully so but as a right from Human
I know there is
camera I want to see that doesn't have
anything to do with yes it does because
then how they tell me I can't take a
fight get on the thing how they tell me
I get on the no how are they telling me
I don't touch me you can't touch me
can't touch me I dare you to touch
me Trina don't make him he
he
[Music]
to stand C
and problem dumb ass attention the door
fo please be sure that you and your
belonging are
clear do you know who I
know that's why I call blood I said when
they
come and they said no I
but they're not going to R because with
the government they done fucked
up that's why I said
arrest I know my fucking rights I didn't
do nothing
WR
exactly I all the
time
that's
un you're doing your
job doing your job but you know what
that's not
fair no fuck you get off the train
you're doing your job nobody we're not
we don't want to arrest you so arrest me
I don't give a fuck arrest me you know
why cuz I got my right come on get off
the train go
the the whole day no he go though right
he can go right yes or
no attention the doors have not closed
properly please be sure that you and
your belongings are
CLE who the fuck is
you fucking right that's not theing not
the way
need a fe officer here no we don't fuck
you do fuck you Hey listen you trust or
going leave or you're getting arrested
trespass after warning okay I got
aard under arrest
how put your behind
your you put your hand behind your back
there you go take that off you don't
need that you're not going to need that
jail Chad Chad take my phone Chad
hold on hold on stand back back Tak
pH
go 115 you show me
1015 you you want to go back over the
terminal you want to go no we'll go want
to go home go you're not going home
now get her ID I don't have ID you're
flying without ID they they let me pass
with proof of what I needed as proof all
right and you're arresting me for no
reason we're arresting you for trespass
after warning disorderly intoxication
I'm not intoxic though how you should
never drink never drink Dr I had what
are you talking
about no do you know how many
people I didn't
walk an
animal I spit in your face not
intentionally you're lying right now not
intentionally you're seeing I spit in
your face on my dead father bro I never
spin in your face you're a
liar sweetheart I spit in his face he
said it wasn't intentional I never in I
never spit in nobody's face you still an
animal no because I want to go home the
I
my you're not you're a liar you got a
new home you're
lying I'm fucking lying I never SP in
nobody's
face this the I was iing to B my
flight
11 we're walking down to
the her
ID she said she doesn't have one my man
has everything in my bag whether she's
lying or not we's TR I'm pull I'm not
lying I didn't say you were I said if
you are or not we don't have it
a means you at least get a night in
jail three HS in
the great balloony sandwich we we tried
to get you to leave man I was leaving no
you w yes I it's on the video you
weren't leaving know you're
[Music]
right
it's not
fair how much do you think you drank
tonight I drank fucking three beers on
my dead
father on my dead father I wasn't even
supposed to come the far and I came my
hip to see his kids three too many beers
I didn't do nothing wrong yes she did no
I You' been act like an animal since I
got I was I acting like an animal M my
do nothing just shut up what are you
talking about you
seeast nasty people no you're being
nasty to everybody sweetheart please if
you know what's right please I do know
what's right that's why I tried to get
you to leave right I was leaving but you
know what
I F you told me that you told me f you
and no I didn't I never said fuck you
you're not effing leaving never said
that on my dead father and my kids that
will die tomorrow okay well I'll watch I
I don't want to Mis categorize what you
said I'll watch the video to make sure
yeah please do because you know what
they're I think Mike's parked out back
never in my life I do
nothing that's not fair pat down real
quick I was going open we're just going
straight out we'll Pat her down out
there
do
that's I don't have any other
information so okay I'll just
[Applause]
start what's your
name
why
your